Yeah.
Oh,
what did I haven't read any papers for
at least a month.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's at once.
Two things.
One of the dumbest moves I've ever heard
of being made by a network.
And also it's what I knew what I first
heard about it when back when they were
telling Jay,
although your ratings are great,
we don't need you to forever so you
know,
a wonderful way to treat the psyche of
the performer,
which is one thing that we're people
never have a clue about.
Um,
and I knew when I first heard it,
this is never going to work.
I don't know how exactly.
I don't pretend to know who I.
10:00 proved to be such an awful time
for a talk show,
but it is the psychology of that much
later when the show's on and people have
had a drink or two and are about to go
to bed and want some entertainment
before nodding off is very different
from how you feel at 10:00 when you
could see law and order another such
shows and,
and it just a natural institute over to
the mess Jay inherited.
And that Conan was,
Wa interestingly pointed out that,
that,
uh,
that hijack offer,
they offered him that cynical thing that
no one in his right mind would accept to
get rid of him.
Um,
when you said that you can have the
tonight show at 12.
Oh,
five.
Well,
somebody including code and pointed out
that 12,
oh,
five is no longer tonight.
It's tomorrow.
So it would have to be called the early,
early show,
but anything but the tonight show,
any managed,
I think to damage to make somewhat
damaged goods of both artists involved.
And they also succeeded in making their
enemy,
David Letterman and vcs competition more
successful in evart.
So whoever is responsible for this
boneheaded move,
we'll,
as we know from watching these things,
certainly within a week or to be
promoted and given a big raise.